let's bring in Dan dockage the ESPN
college basketball analyst Continental
Tire Coach's Corner the former Bowling
Green and Indiana head coach coach how
are you today man I'm with you that
thing was really kind of stupid it was
like what are you doing that whole
dollar thing I didn't get it and if
you're gonna have it you do have to kind
of respect James Worthy but I think
you're selling patio a little bit short
he was involved in a lot of pretty good
games he not James Worthy you can make
the argument in college you might have
been when he didn't play as long as
Battier did you play against worthy in
college now really left
we played North Carolina 84 he was gone
81 Indiana beat North Carolina and I was
not there worthy was and I think worthy
was either a zinc well he'd be a senior
- I don't know but he was gone no worthy
was there in 83 when they won he got the
ball from Freddy Brown was that yeah
that was 882 yeah yes yeah I know we
didn't play against I was a freshman to
senior we didn't play against them who
was the best player you played against
you owe Michael Jordan was pretty good
but you know there was a kid at Purdue
and it's gonna sound weird he led the
Big Ten in scoring named Keith Edmondson
yeah he was a first-round pick like the
way Purdue played offense he was really
like he was hard to guard like Jordan
that's gonna sound stupid but don't let
him rebound that kind of stuff early kid
named Fred Jenkins at Tennessee was a
mother to guard did you guard your night
did you get to guard Jordan no I mean no
every depends George does Jordan know
who you are
Jordan got heckled so I'm from just
outside Chicago Jordan and I play golf
he owed me six grand after the round of
golf true story big big it was
today he signed his Nike contract we
were playing in 84 at the Olympic Trials
me all for Timmy night in Jordan I was
pretty good he was pretty bad we started
betting got to the 16th hole it was dark
we ended up on me six grand he tried to
pay me with a bag full of like free
stuff from the Olympic Danny he's trying
to give me clean pocket jeans there have
been over the years guy who built his
house was an Indiana grad he's back a
lot of people have coach or in the Bobby
but he still owes you six grand Dan I
used to write him a letter true story I
did basketball camp in Gary Indiana my
high school and I wrote him a letter
every year
I knew his address all right let's dive
into the topic here should Zion
Williamson shut it down the rest of the
season you know you always go by what
you would do I would I would play cuz I
like to play but I've never been faced
with the money that he's faced with
right and I think a little bit of it
depends on the need you know Dan one of
the things about a sprained knee is that
that's basically an ACL I mean it's him
not great let me put you this way the
only way I can answer that is I would
not do it because I like to play if he
did it I wouldn't be mad at him because
the world is in 1984 the world isn't me
the world is him and all the money and
that he's looking at and it's
generational and you know he's a one
thing design williamson has proven I
don't know how you guys feel about this
but he's proven he loves the game and he
loves teammates and he loves Duke and he
loves ball and some guys have to prove
that he doesn't have to prove that so if
he shut it down I would go I oh I
wouldn't blame him but I personally
wouldn't do it and I hope he doesn't cuz
he's just too much fun to walk
yeah it's a whole different era a whole
different world we had Patrick Ewing on
first hour and I said what would you do
and he said I would play because I came
there to play and you can't sit there
and think about the the risk of an
injury you know but there's no Patrick's
old school as well because he's you know
talking about the early eighties when he
was playing I get it and I said the same
thing I don't blame him if he said he
was gonna shut it down and I don't you
know I I don't blame him if he says look
I'm gonna play this is why I came to
Duke it's his decision it's everybody
around the echo chamber that is talking
about their agenda about kids should get
paid they shouldn't have to go to
college get rid of the one-and-done
like all of these things come up and
then they're just using Zion Williamson
to further their crusade here
yeah I've been driving I heard your
interview with Patrick and I heard you
say that about the agenda and I damn
near started applauding because
everybody's trying to be the next guy
right the next social media justice
warrior you know where you're the guy
that you know tells everybody how it is
and the n-c-double-a is awful and Duke
stinks Nikes are worse it's all their
agenda and you're right you're exactly
right you know but to me again if I look
at it from Patrick Ewing's perspective
and you guys were so right Patrick Ewing
was the guy like Patrick Ewing was going
to be the first pick in the NBA Draft
and truthfully if he came out of high
school I don't know the draft he's my
age so he came out of high school in 81
I don't know who was drafted number one
two or three and 81 and but if Patrick
went out of high street probably was the
number one pick Ben so he I appreciate
what patrick said I really do why I also
think a man this is this kids like him
this is this kids you know future again
he's been the big Dan I would say this
and we've had this discussion among our
crew on Tuesdays and Saturdays what's
the second most interesting story in
college basketball other than Zion
Williamson and the answer is nobody
seems to have one it's like he's he's so
dynamic that he's kind of swallowed up
so from up from a purely selfish
standpoint I hope he comes back
mark acquire Isiah Thomas buck Williams
1981 drowned that's pretty good draft
now Ewing would still go because back
then the big man was still more valued I
mean Isiah was great I would have taken
Isaiah had such a like I say it through
the interview because he wanted his
buddy go to the first in the draft
Maguire he just you know I there's one
in my opinion I meet people wait wait
wait wait wait hold on
Isaiah through the interview so he
wouldn't be the number one pick yeah
yeah he threw it he he acted in such a
manner that he wouldn't he wanted a
glider to be the number one pick they
were boys and mm mortars Flyers so yeah
I say I went into the interview and well
however you throw an interview I don't
know usually when I'm interview and I'm
trying to get the you know what I mean
and some wire goes Dallas number one
yeah okay yeah that was big to a client
it wasn't big Isaiah so he and he had a
lot of respect like he was going to go
to DePaul the word honest because of AG
liar but he ended up saying now go play
for coach so I'm talking to Dan dockage
ESPN college basketball analyst toasted
the dandaka show on 1070 the fan in
Indianapolis I mentioned this first hour
she probably heard it but what bothered
me you know obviously the injury to Zion
but man I gotta have RJ Barrett and
camera at her step up in a big game here
at home and that's what was more
alarming is everybody sort of went now
what do we do
nobody was trying to get to the hole you
had only two guys who had a cyst on
Duke's team last night and if you make
them shoot threes you can beat him so
that to me was the big picture that I
took away from the game last night what
about you Dan I did hear that and you so
right I mean
okay Dukes down to only what for
McDonald's all management in the first
draft that's all they're down to now
what you can't you can't guard
you can't sprint back on defense you
can't take you said it you can't take
the ball to the rim I heard when you
said that and then I thought the same
thing like look you're at home too and I
get it Roy Williams you guys have been
playing Roy's take and you know okay Roy
said oh you know alright big deal it is
in middle of the game thirty-six seconds
whatever it was but man it's it's time
for if you are that good if you are well
more importantly if you are that top and
you're RJ Baird are your cameras go get
forty like you know I mean go don't get
filed get to the line twenty times I
mean if the threes aren't going I'm with
you I it was almost like I looked at
Duke and said alright you got this
Brotherhood you got all these guys
everything has to go perfect for you you
know you lost a guy I'm not saying they
could have won because I thought North
Carolina was playing at a really high
level and I thought Kobe white was
Rihanna at the point guard but and
obviously Luke Mae was tremendous but
man you can't run back on defense get
organized you can't defend a little bit
like you said go to the rim I was
shocked by how I want to say unorganized
they were but it seemed that way Duke
seemed like they were it was like a
glorified AAU game from their side of it
it it just wasn't what Duke should be
about even if they lose a guy are you
going to the Final Four I think so I
don't have my schedule yet from ESPN I
do the slam dunk contest and hangout
yeah yeah I hope so
well why why didn't you respond to my
text yesterday uh because it's Wednesday
and my wife on Wednesdays dictates that
we we do something with each other and
we put our phones away so I didn't see
any any text messages till today but so
you didn't text me today well I knew I
was gonna talk to you Dan and and I
thought you know what I'll talk to you
here but you know that is bad of me I
usually am a pretty pretty good
returning tax particularly two
superstars in the end
Streetman so they're right I bend the
knee I genuflect can you and you've been
calling out to dance though you've been
calling out the dance for their lack of
shoot and vice versa so we're gonna be
in Minneapolis and there's a couple of
dance
McLovin and Seaton who would like a
piece of you I've seen McLovin shoot
there is a little bit of trepidation by
me Seaton I don't know I'm not seeing
him shoot I think he was the poster
child for only Dan Patrick shoots on the
Dan Patrick show that means that doesn't
mean I'm right but I tell you what every
once awhile McLovin I'll post a video
where he stares me down on Twitter and
drills a shot for about 26 feet and then
I must say it is intimidating and and I
so I immediately go out to my driveway
and get a couple jump shots and did my
shoulder hurts and I go back inside and
drink there well we're gonna be a
Minneapolis and if you want to stop well
you know and it doesn't matter matter
the weather I mean we playing conditions
we're from the Midwest
you know we're hearty Souls we play well
shovel off the driveway for need this I
can guarantee you and I know you have
Reggie Allah wishes pillar on your show
and he lit me up my final game in
college in the garden but I will say
this I don't care if it's Reggie Miller
Ray Allen Michael Jordan dan Patrick
McLovin seat and anybody I am the best
in the dark shooter in America I don't
care so if you want to go somewhere
shoot at night play in the dark shoot in
the dark Jim I will take anybody on
anytime anywhere and go from there
that's all I'm saying ok so the lights
are completely out if you can see the
rim I can beat you but if it's if it's
however dark you want it to be well but
if we can see the rim okay you gotta be
able to see the rim and maybe even not
see the rim hell I don't know I mean I
just know this if the lights are out
I am the best shooter in America and I
will challenge anybody to that
this is what I'll do for you I will go
in to the gym prior to your arrival and
shoot the lights out and then you can
come in okay my nickname was the
electrician in high school because I
would turn I would shoot the light I'd
turn the lights out I stopped the other
one I liked your commercials though I do
like your camera you become like I don't
know you become like Allstate guy
everywhere every time I turn my TV on
you're on a freakin commercial about
tires and wine and thanks for coming on
and I'll check back in with you not that
you'll get back to me because obviously
you're pretty important but uh you know
hopefully we'll see you at the Final
Four that will never happen again I'm
gonna go have a talk with myself who do
you love more me or your wife oh I have
to say my wife I've been through one
divorce but you know what your first
wife took your jump shot so that was it
that's a shame she got your jump shot
[Laughter]
I'll talk to you soon Dan dockage former
coach played for Bob Knight he still has
a sense of humor and he played for Bob
Knight I think you have to have a sense
of humor if you play for Bob Knight
former college coaches well now working
for ESPN as a college basketball analyst
Continental Tire Coach's Corner
Continental Tire for what you do for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show at
you